moving on recently enough
astrobiology has been pretty much making
the headlines
and the topics like origin of life on
earth as well as the search for life on
mars are some of the most exciting
topics in this domain and it gives me
immense pleasure to welcome professor
shiladi sharma who will be talking about
us extremophiles and the search for life
on mars dr dash sharma is the pioneering
microbiologist well known for his
contributions to the genomics molecular
biology and biotechnology of archaea
especially in the field of astrobiology
he earned his phd degree in biochemistry
from the massachusetts institute of
technology and bs degree in chemistry
from
indiana university bloomington prior to
taking the faculty position he conducted
numerous researches at the massachusetts
general hospital howard medical school
and pathu institute pahi
before joining the institute of marine
and environmental technology university
of maryland school of medicine he was a
professor at the university of
massachusetts amherst and the university
of maryland biotechnology institute
he has over 150 scientific publications
and years of mentorship experience he is
a founder of umd gpi analysis genomics
track and is the gump institutional
representative for the system-wide nes
graduate program he is also an affiliate
research scientist at blue marble space
institute of science so without any
further ado let me welcome professor
over to you professor
thank you thank you very much uh can you
hear me
yeah we can hear your file
okay good uh so uh
thank you very much for that kind
introduction and uh
as mentioned we are going to be uh
moving a little bit away from
some of the problems we have here on
earth
such as covid and and cancer
i wanted to share with you uh in this
slide a picture of the earth
taken from voyager 1 of 30 years ago
actually 30 year years ago from
yesterday
and here's here is the earth it's about
4 billion
you're
miles away
and so everything that happens here
including our
wearing of masks or
transmission of copid
is uh put into perspective in the
universe
so we can leave the
planet for at least a little bit
and we can think a little bit about uh
the new science of astrobiology
and astrobiology
is more than a science it's almost a
philosophy in some ways
and there are some uh obvious unanswered
questions that uh humans have uh thought
about for a long time and some of these
are
what are the limits to life
and how did life even evolve on earth
and uh in fact what is life
and are we alone
how can we find if life exists elsewhere
so these are all questions that
astrobiologists ask and i think that
hopefully i can convince you during my
talk
that bioinformatics is the tool that we
need to answer some of those questions
so um it's an interdisciplinary science
of you know biology and astronomy and
astrophysics
on the left uh there's some astronomical
numbers even from the biology side so
uh
scientists have estimated the number of
cells
on earth as being greater than
10 to the 30th
which is actually
greater than the number of stars
estimated in the universe
and almost all of these cells are of
course prokaryotes
and these prokaryotic cells
exist from the subsurface to the
stratosphere on earth in fact a large
majority
is estimated to be in the subsurface
and many of these cells are
extremophiles they live in extreme
environments on earth
not at 25 degrees
in
as we do
and these extremophiles go by various
names like thermophiles methanogens
halophiles etc
and these cells in addition to providing
us with insight into astrobiology
they've also been very practically
helpful in
finding uh resources or being resources
for biotechnology
and uh genomics and omics and methods in
general have been very useful for
developing these biotechnological
resources
on the astro side uh there
are an estimated uh billion earth-like
planets in the universe
so the question of are we alone perhaps
uh can be
at least considered from that
perspective it seems pretty unlikely
and in fact astronomers have been
discovering planets outside of our solar
system out of the nine planets in the in
our solar system and have discovered
over 4 000 including
several uh dozen uh earth-like planets
and in fact i think you may have heard
in the news there's a lot of excitement
about a life-finding mission that was
launched last year
it's going to take 10 years but mars
2020 was the beginning of that the
perseverance rover was launched by nasa
landed on mars and is currently taking
samples
searching for ancient life and with
the ultimate plan of returning samples
back to earth for analysis perhaps some
metagenomic analysis
and then finally there's also been
discussions about whether life might
actually exist on mars today
except life if you will and uh the idea
is that uh if it exists it would
probably be found in refuge
such as in salt and ice caves or even
subsurface
so
while we don't know whether life exists
for sure elsewhere we do know it exists
here on earth and uh
life on earth has certain uh features
that i just want to briefly go through
there's both a unity
and also a diversity of life the unity
is that all life on earth is composed of
the same
uh six chemicals six elements
c h n o p and s
it all occurs in a
h2o medium and the biopolymers are all
the same dna rna proteins
polysaccharides and lipids although
there are two different types of lipids
and the molecular biology is amazingly
unified the central dogma
characterizes the information flow
and the universal genetic code which was
discovered
by
my phd mentor
a.g karana and others
really underscores the
unity of all life and in fact on the
right
you can see the luca the red ball that's
the original last universal common
ancestor and that must have had this
genetic code because
all life on earth
contains the same
essential genetic code
also the energy currency is all the same
atp and the cellular membrane with a
proton motive force
however we all know that there's a huge
diversity on earth of life
and in fact most of that diversity is in
prokaryotes and archaea and bacteria uh
of course viruses as well uh allow me to
add that
after the last two
uh three presentations
uh so there are an estimated 10 to the
12 species of
prokaryotic cells
and the
arrows show the three domain view of
life
and so the extant life here on earth are
either eukaryotes or
and bacteria
how these formed is still in the realm
of
the unknown
they probably evolved pretty early after
the formation of the earth maybe about
four billion years ago
and we really don't know what happened
during that first
half
the first two billion or so years
but we know that there must have been a
cellular form that established itself
luca and that cellular form had the
genetic code it had chemiosmotic
coupling and then soon afterwards it
must have developed a genome
and developed metabolism like phototroph
respiration photosynthesis synthesis etc
so how do we address uh these kinds of
questions what happened during the first
two billion years of our planets
of life's
evolution well
one way is to study these diverse
extremophiles and i just listed a few of
these on this slide and
the first is our zero files these grow
in a very dry places like the atacama
desert
they they use very little they need very
little water for survival
psychophiles such as uh
one that i'll be talking about halo
reuben like us for funding is from
antarctica and can grow at sub-zero
temperatures
and it also
ends up being also a halophile which uh
are
tolerant of very high salinity in fact
they can survive
in
salt that's
250 million years old
and then there are other
limits to life that
people are studying such as
uh alkaline conditions alkalophiles
acidophiles
and then
there are some very uh well-known
methanogens thermophiles and
hyperthermophiles that
microbiologists also study
so these organisms are so fascinating
that they were
one of the reasons why genomic
technologies were developed and also
genomic technologies were developed
using some of their uh molecules
and so this is a timeline taken from an
asm news which is a precursor to microbe
that you might be familiar with american
society for microbiology it had actually
a foldout of the cover showing a
timeline of genome sequencing so
historically the first genome of course
was in 1995 muscles influenza
however the ones that are boxed those
are all extremophiles so you can see in
the first five or so years
uh about a third of the
three dozen or so genomes that were
sequenced were extremophilic genomes and
that was because of the
extreme interest in uh early evolution
origin of life
so
we
started our project immediately after
the haemophilus project and it took us
about five years to complete it
uh which may surprise some of the
students in the audience that it took
five years he published it in uh just
before
2001 in october of 2000
and we had about uh 50 authors and from
12 different institutions
so the organism that we sequence taylor
bacterium is a halophilic archaea and it
is a poly extremophile like most of
these so not only is it able to grow in
saturating
concentrations of salt
it's also able to tolerate long periods
of desiccation
low oxygen tension
high solar irradiance
and
sometimes elevated or freezing
temperatures and the genome sequence
genome map behind it just shows our
first
fold-out genome that we published in the
proceedings the national academy of
sciences
all of these
extremes are also present on
mars
there's no oxygen really but otherwise
it's very similar so uh there was a lot
of interest right away in
whether
these hilophilic archaea could
survive on
on mars excuse me
so um
this is one of the figures that we
published an integrated view of the
biology and you can see it's it's
complex
we were able to get essentially a
bird's-eye view of the biology of the
organism and i would like to go through
some of the details
during the next few minutes
so one of the most interesting results
that we found
was that the proteins predicted by the
genome
were
unimodal in distribution with respect to
their pi or electronic uh isoelectric
point
uh the red uh peak shows that
the halobacterium proteins are
essentially all very acidic they have a
average pi of under
five
and uh that's in contrast to all of the
other organisms which have a bimodal
distribution of proteins both acidic and
basic with an essentially neutral
proteome
so why is this well
because of the high salinity inside of
the cell
there's actually a reduced concentration
of water it's about 25
salt by weight and what that does is it
results in
what's uh you may know about is salting
out
so the salts dissolve the water that
causes crowding of the proteins and then
the proteins would precipitate out
uh the way in which the cells or the
proteins prevent themselves from
precipitation is through mutual
repulsion caused by the surface negative
charges or the negative charges on the
protein
so here is a structure of a protein that
we've been studying for
a few years now it's a it's a family 42
beta galactosidase and uh you can see
the red acidic and blue
basic residues and in comparison to a
non-halophilic thermos thermophilus
enzyme
and i think you can see that there are
more red and fewer blue and in fact the
charge on the halo archaeal protein
is about
minus 65 as opposed to -4 for the
thermos protein
so this
allows both mutual repulsion and also
binding more tightly to
the water that's available
so if you look at the activity of
proteins like this they're of interest
from a biotechnological perspective
the proteins can function usually
optimally function
in close to saturated uh sodium chloride
or potassium chloride concentrations
and they as a result of their type
binding to water they can also
function in organic solvents
so this is a very unusual and
interesting and potentially useful
property that
may be used for
development of new catalysts
another
interesting result from our first genome
was that
the three domain view of life was
essentially confirmed so the the tree is
an unrooted tree of life using
uh the small ribosomal rna this was
pioneered by carl rose
uh showed that
the hypothesis was that uh prokaryotes
are divided into two
uh the archaea and the bacteria and they
are distinct from the higher organisms
that you carry on the left
in the bottom
on the left
uh
tree however
we do see the same uh three domains of
life however there's some interesting uh
differences the purple
circle is showing the hilophile the
halophile here seems to be a branch of a
methanogen here however over here the
halophile is coming out much closer to
the root what would be considered the
root of the tree if you had rooted it
so
the halo bacterium actually changes its
position it's it has a dynamic phylogeny
if you will
and uh
the we did some additional work with
this uh looking at different bacteria
and uh in this case we took a
cyanobacterium dinococcus radiodurans
and uh a uh
ilicus
and we found that halobacterium is this
deeply branching hello
branching
archaeon excuse me
however if you use bacillus pseudomonas
and e coli it actually becomes a
bacterium
so why is that
well it turns out that there are a whole
lot of bacterial genes in our
halobacterium genome right here
and uh more than in any of the other
archaea similarly there are some
bacteria over here which have archaeal
genes
dermatoga is one of these
so these types of fine endings raise the
that
not all genes in a particular organism
are
original
originally from that
lineage and some of them have been
inherited not by vertical
transmission but by horizontal
transmission so these are presumably
horizontally transferred genes
so those are pretty interesting uh
results that we got early on uh and i've
been doing bioinformatics for a long
time so uh this that really went back to
the last century and i had to show you
this
uh these uh
figure from nih showing
uh the different generations of uh
genome sequencing so the genome
sequencing cost has been of concern for
a long time and it's been going down
quite fast
and in electronics we know of the
moore's law it's a reduction every every
two years and that happened
with
sanger sequencing for a while
and then of course uh illumina and a
whole bunch of other genome sequencing
methods came in second
gen
and uh although the costs dropped
the quality also wasn't quite
the same as with sanger and then now we
have the third gen and the cost
according to the latest
from is uh down to a thousand dollars
per human genome
so of course for a micro genome that's
even much less
and here is a figure from gold showing
that there are something like 350 000
prokaryotic genomes in the database at
ncbi now
so as soon as there were more genomes
available and we also contributed to
some additional genomes we started doing
something that roman taurusov
initiated at nh
and that was reciprocal blasting so this
was the idea was to take one protein
from a genome and blast it against the
second one
and do the reciprocal blast as well so
this is the computationally intensive
but it results in some very interesting
results which is that you find what are
called reciprocal best hits and those
reciprocal best hits allow you to
form clusters of
proteins
or orthologous groups called cogs
we did this for
the halo archaea and found
that there are about 800
uh
core
proteins so these are proteins that have
presumably the same function their
orthologs in the two different organisms
and you can see that many
however there are some that are poorly
characterized or even that there are no
associated in this case no associated
bacterial
clusters of orthologous groups so these
are essentially signature genes that
means these proteins are present in all
the halo archaea but nothing else
so they're in fact a signature how these
organisms perhaps survive
then there's the concept of the pan
genome so there are many other genes
or proteins which are not found in all
of the genomes in fact the largest
number
are unique
and if you look at that of the
forty four hundred
halo alkyl orthologous groups
uh about thirty four hundred thirty six
hundred are in the pan genome
so this is the total
uh gene
content
and that
is
the most interesting part because that's
in the realm of the unknown
so
uh we wanted to get more into more
detail uh analysis of the genomes of
these organisms
and
as several have mentioned it's a
combination of both experimental and
bioinformatics
i'm not going to be able to go into the
details but just give you a couple of uh
examples
of what we've done
so
the
physiology of hillary is very
interesting from the standpoint of
growth in different concentrations of
oxygen and also with light they
photophosphorylate because they have
these membrane pumps that pump protons
and allow the cells to produce atp
they can also grow
by both aerobic and anaerobic
respiration and they also have substrate
level phosphorylation so they're able to
tolerate different concentrations of
oxygen and these properties again i
won't be able to go into in detail but
they're very unique and uh
useful so for instance
when they're photo
photo
growing phototrophically
they produce these intracellular
nanoparticles called gas vesicles which
allow them to float and we're using
these nanoparticles as a vehicle for
vaccines and for drug delivery
then these purple membrane patches are
also being used for a variety of other
biotechnological applications
but with regard to bioinformatics we
initiated uh transcriptomic analysis
during the dna microarray
era
and we for instance tested the uh
gene expression under anaerobic
respiration versus aerobic respiration
fermentation versus aerobic respiration
or anaerobic respiration versus
fermentation and we saw changes in
different genes
and to make a long story short
if you look on the right
essentially the cells are have a
hierarchy of responses from
aerobic respiration
when the redox goes down it goes to
bacteriodopsin based phototrophy
then
a lower redux
uh if the there's a certain uh
compounds available for anaerobic
respirations like dmso tmao not in some
cases nitrate or even perchlorate
they can uh
survive by anaerobic respiration
and if there's um if there are no uh
terminal electron acceptors at all but
there are some substrates like arginine
they can still survive through
fermentation
so they're quite versatile organisms in
this way
the other very interesting property of
hilo archaea is that
they are incredibly radiation resistant
so you can see here the the killing
curves
uh they're almost as uh tolerant as
dinococcus ray endurance in terms of uv
light and uh they're able to repair uv
light with the photolyze uh and i won't
go into the details in this figure but
basically they have a photo liase that
allows them to re do direct photo repair
they also have a uvr abc
to repair
a do darker pair of uvv damage
and so here again we've mutated the
evr abc and you can see that the
cells are not able to survive and we
could do transcriptional or we did do
transcriptomic results and we could see
which gene uh genes are actually
affected by uv light and you can see
it's a very small number so the cis
system is very highly developed
uh
in terms of being able to
survive uv light
but um it does not seem to resemble the
bacterial sos type response
and then uh
hillary are also resistant to ionizing
radiation and this was a bit of a
surprise although ionizing radiation of
course results in double-stranded breaks
and that is something that they probably
have to deal with when they are
desiccated because desiccation also
results in that so the the
gel on the left shows you
after ionizing radiation the genome
becomes broken into about 20 pieces
and then after one or two generations
they stitch that back together and
they're perfectly fine
so we went through a uh experiment where
we treated with a
killing dose of
ionizing radiation in this case we use
linac
and then we allow them to recover and we
did this three or four times and then we
isolated mutants and tested their
ability to tolerate ionizing radiation
and what we found is very interesting
shown here which is the uh survival
fraction increased quite dramatically
so these are the the mutants that had
survived these multiple rounds of uh
killing doses
and you can see that they're actually
more resistant than dinococcus
radiodurans
so they also have a very interesting
way of
uh being able to tolerate ionizing
radiation and our transcriptomic results
showed that they upregulate only one
operon and that codes for a eukaryotic
type of single-stranded dna binding
protein
so we've done some additional work on
this to show that over expression of
these proteins actually results in
increased radiation resistance so this
may be of interest uh going forward as
we consider sending uh astronauts to
mars
so finally
uh the last thing i want to tell you
about is are some experiments to see
whether halo archaea could actually
survive on mars
so the closest we could get to mars
was uh earth's stratosphere and this is
basically showing
the atmospheric pressure
ozone uh
h2o and temperature
uh higher in this in the atmosphere this
is the troposphere the the stratosphere
is maybe 30 kilometers up
it's very similar to mars up there there
are to the surface of mars
the temperatures are similar has similar
ev flux elevated cosmic
rays electrons protons very low pressure
and it's very dry
so we did an experiment with
collaborators in california
uh where we
sent cultures by airplane to california
from which a point that they launched
them into the stratosphere
and then they recovered it and then they
sent it back to us for analysis
so uh again to make a long story short
we we tested two different hillarq
the
h laccis profundi which as i mentioned
before
is a
cold adapted organism actually it was
isolated from
antarctica
and our lab strain nrc1 and you can see
that after the balloon flight
there is survival in both cases however
if you look at the uh the difference
here
nrc1
sorry uh hilar ruben lux friendly versus
nrc1 you can see that the hilary uber
and lacaze better able to survive uh
stratospheric condition so this one
would presumably do better on mars and
the reasons for that are in the paper
and again i'm going to have to skip over
it but i encourage you to go and take a
look
and very very
fine thing is that there are a lot of
perchlorate salts these very uh
oxidizing salts which are actually used
for
oxidizer for rocket fuel
on the surface of mars
it's very toxic of course to most living
organisms but it turns out that
paleo bacteria are able to survive
tolerate them pretty well and in fact
with halorubrum they're actually able to
grow using perchlorate as the terminal
electron acceptor
so we also have transcriptomic results
from these experiments
so um finally
i just want to leave you with uh
the picture of
nasa and issa and also the
chinese
space administration
they're all
going to uh mars uh nasa and esa are
collaborating on this
mars 2020 as i mentioned uh is currently
has has delivered perseverance rover and
ingenuity
the helicopter to the surface of mars
you may have seen some spectacular
pictures
they're drilling samples so this is a
pretty elaborate um set of plants here's
the earth here's mars uh so this rover
is on mars it's collecting samples it's
going to collect samples from several
different places in a in a an ancient
river delta called
jezero
and it's going to put these samples in
in various places
to be picked up by a second rover which
is going to deliver it to
a spot from which it will be returned
back to earth
and it's going to uh
i believe it's going to be analyzed in a
laboratory in the u.s
and um
so we may very well be able to learn
whether there was ever life on mars
this particular
mission which will take as i said 10
years is going to be
for ancient life
so
the river delta is a place where they
would find sediments that might have
preserved some
signatures of life
however
some of us that
have gone to nasa meetings where there's
also discussions about other missions to
look for extent life
and uh
there are four areas where uh scientists
feel that there may in fact be extant
life on mars
uh that includes uh ice both polar
and mid-latitude ice
salt deposits which of course is of
great interest to us
and also subsurface such as in lava
tubes
caves
and then there are a lot of people who
are very interested in the deep
subsurface there's a lot of water in the
deep south surface about a kilometer
below the surface of mars and so
there may in fact be some
uh
extant organisms that might be found
there of course you have to drill down a
kilometer to get to that location and by
the way
if they were there uh the subsurface
water is also extremely salty so uh they
would probably also be halophiles
so um
then i just want to conclude by saying
that uh astrobiology is i think a very
interesting new science uh with some
very good practical applications and the
need for bioinformatics
and it's informed at the present time
until we get samples from mars by many
extremophilic forms on here on earth
the genome sequencing in the omics
revolution have provided insights into
the limits of life of these
extremophilic
forms
our focus has been the halo archaea
but
these and other extremophilic genomes
have led to concepts like how proteins
can function in
extreme conditions horizontal gene
transfers and evolution of life
and core and pan genomes
and then hillary cure adapted to poly
extremophilic conditions including the
ones that i just discussed about
low oxygen
high radiation
cold temperatures and
perchlorates
and halophiles are considered as a model
microbes
for survival and martian stressors
and just finally
astrobiology is fascinating however
we also need to make a living here on
earth so i just want to mention
that
there are some real revolutions in
biotechnology including of course
the discovery of thermostable
polymerases which was
probably the biggest development however
there are many others such as the ones
i've listed up here
so
i just want to end there and uh thank uh
the organizers and and uh the audience
for your attention and there have been
our lab has been in operation since 1986
so we've had a lot of people who've gone
through the lab i especially want to
thank
priya dasarma who has been a close
collaborator for 30 years and uh
and uh all of the other lab members and
of course the funding has been uh
absolutely essential for our work and uh
right now we have funding from nasa and
nih and
in the past we've had quite a lot of
funding from nsf
and if you're interested in our genomes
i encourage you to go to our website
which is halo.umbc.edu
so i'll stop there and
i don't know if they're time for
questions but i'd be happy to answer
them